the domino effect continues just 15 days
after winning the World Cup Spain's
women's team coach Jorge vilda has been
sacked vilda had supported his colleague
when Football Federation president Luis
rubialis refused to step down after
kissing Spanish player Jenny hermoso she
said the kiss was not consensual
yet it's Wilder getting sacked because
rubialis is an elected official while
vilda is not
we can call that he was the weakest link
in the royales Entourage and uh right
now he had no players to to call for the
national league because all of that
women resigned 11 of his staff have
resigned as well
the logical thing to do Wilder had been
under fire even before the World Cup
when 15 players went on strike because
of his coaching methods
it should have been done earlier when
they were already complaints and I think
there is still a lot of change to be
done in the Federation
they know better what happened but come
on they won the World Cup so I guess he
did well as a coach
Spain's Football Federation has released
this video presenting the team's first
female coach in an attempt to reduce
Fallout from rubialis's career-ending
Kiss monseto May was filled as Deputy
since 2018. in this context of the
conflict with with uh
that a woman has been appointed as the
manager of the national team I think I
think it sends the right kind of method
the Spanish Football Federation has
issued an apology for the quote immense
damage that was done by the kissing
Scandal the appointment of a female
coach could be the start of a new era in
the Spanish game Dimitri medvedenko Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera